[Music]
better to fight and fall than to live
without hope
[Music]
to take up great resolutions and then to
lay them aside only ends in dishonor
no one is a total fool if he knows when
to hold his tongue
nothing good can happen to people who
break their solemn vows foreign
it is an old custom for the wisest to
give way
a person's actions are often worse than
their intentions
[Music]
stubbornness brings either greater
humiliation or greater honor
when truth and fairness are different
from what is law
better it is to follow truth than
fairness
[Music]
the brave man shall fight well and win
though dull his blade may be
that which has a bad beginning is likely
to have a bad ending
numbers cannot withstand skill
often it is that anger is blind to the
truth
[Music]
everyone has some friend even among his
enemies
this Palace is an easy place to enter
but a hard place to leave
there's no excusing the man who rejects
the truth once it's proven
IL seed has been sown an ill crop will
spring from it
wise men whole that distance is the cure
for rage
a rotten Branch will be found in every
tree
Eagles should show their claws though
dying
only idlers wait till evening
[Music]
forethought is better than afterthought
the one you trust most can disappoint
you most
there are few more certain tokens of ill
than not to know how to accept the good
be warned by another's woe
[Music]
old friends are the last to break away
[Music]
nothing ventured nothing gained
[Music]
what brothers own jointly is best seen
together
[Music]
the run of the game is decided by the
first move
[Music]
no man is his own creator
[Music]
who dares wins
[Music]
a wise man does all things in moderation
[Music]
youth is hasty
[Music]
luck a company's wisdom
short is the life of the proud
[Music]
the reason young men get nowhere is they
overestimate their obstacles
many eyes squint when there's money
around
a man without wisdom is lacking in much
many hands make light work
[Music]
it takes time to know people
a small bird makes a small catch
better it is to have a lower position in
life and be free than to have a position
of power only to be subject to the will
of another
the pool is busy in everyone's business
but his own
[Music]
a Hungry Wolf is bound to wage a hard
battle
[Music]
bravery is half the victory
[Music]
that another's wounds be your warning
[Music]
word carries though mouth stands still
[Music]
evil grows from evil
better to Die With Honor than to live
with shame
once back is vulnerable unless one has a
brother
a man should have his plans were doubt
before he enters into great undertakings
or incites others to them
[Music]
foreign who can say what sorrow
seemingly Carefree folk bear to their
life's end
[Music]
great deeds and Ill Deeds often fall
within each other's Shadow
gold is little comfort for the Kinsmen
dead
wisdom is welcome wherever it comes from
ill is the result of letting fear rule
thine actions
a learned man's heart whose learning is
deep seldom sings with joy
the Bold succeed wherever they go
[Music]
oftentimes it is not numbers that win
the victory but those who move forward
with the most vigor
when men meet foes in fight better is
Stout heart than sharp sword
[Music]
every man must plow his own furrow
fear not death for the hour of your doom
is set and none may Escape it
a person should not agree today to what
they'll regret tomorrow
stand by your own trial not by what
others say
ill it is to abandon honor and integrity
in exchange for Injustice and greed
often is their regret for saying too
much but seldom for saying too little
[Music]
if you hear the Fool's word of a drunken
man strive not with him who is drunk
with drink and witness for often only
ill and doom come out of such things
only a coward waits to be taken like a
lamb from the fold or a fox from a trap
beware of those who speak fairly but
think falsely
[Music]
never swear false Souls great and Grim
is the reward for the breaking of a
trough
[Music]
Kinsmen to Kinsmen should be true
the thrall alone takes instant Vengeance
the coward never
[Music]
where wolves ears are wolves teeth are
near
[Music]
too much ale and a man's heart is laid
open for all to see
eyes cannot hide a woman's love for a
man
[Music]
ill it is to take love from another
man's wife
foreign
[Music]